oh no good cat came at that chicken
sandwich I'm on I feel like I'm a hot
ones right now real quick you're white
so when cat goes hey [ __ ] house whites
you want your chicken sandwich we want
it white hot cat mean lot for me damnit
cat I saw a single tear I know I to
medium I feel so sick living fasting all
day that was a bad idea
I mean I feel like you put hot coals in
my mouth I'm dying right but why the
left I just crying
there's your feminine that's my per vine
hey is there even hotter than the hot
yeah there is extra hot and then howling
chin would you get I got medium what do
I have you have hot medium to your
medium hot but mine's medium but I want
to enjoy I don't like what behinds doing
right now should be at the Thai hot
Tommy Cod or whatever my poor out what
should have got howling I'll get you
guys that's not going in its going in my
[ __ ] but you know different peppers
have different effects for me jalapenos
are the worst coming out all those ain't
[ __ ] those are the worst feel me but I
can I can have like I can live like ha
Buffalo I'm fine
I have a hot curry Green crack [ __ ] me
up though yeah just depends right yeah
real the spicy food in the world's like
real Thai food like real Thai hot it's
fuel to actual Thai place which I've
been with our friend buster cm but so cm
if we go there it's like you can't you
can't finish the goddamn know who's
eating that you know why they use spicy
food of spices and food you know stupid
question oh there's those young peppers
that have that tingly thing if you ever
had those ones there's like young
peppers ah and they get them you can go
to like yeah you get like a young young
type of pepper near this tingle in your
mouth it's hot but it's also like tingly
whether you have a nice pop rock Oh
weird yeah it's like a pop rock but hot
pepper no I don't mind a reaper all that
we've been over this
Carolina Reaper now is that just in the
Carolinas is that an American pepper
yeah they like a hybrid of two different
purposes
Carolina Reaper yeah I heard of that my
head's on my head's hot my head's on
fire what did you say I can't hear you
my um my hearing went down by only that
[ __ ] look at that that long that looks
like when they took for the heart out
Jones so looks like a heaven yeah looks
like a bad one look like that looks like
a rectal prolapse actually it's called a
pocket like a rectal prolapse it comes
in a pucker but pepper company who can
eat [ __ ] you Kat I can eat a spicy white
note hey we have our bring Marcus on the
podcast we should fly introduce him
everybody knows Aubree I know but his
voice has a unique timbre yeah that's
you smell good and I'll say it smells
good yeah I'm a little huggy buggy and I
and I it smells like [ __ ] wormwood
kicks smells like wormwood those are
Gucci huh uh-huh
hey sweet booths Brian Brennan these are
my bloodstone Australia don't insult the
continent of Australia I want those I'm
to you Wow
I don't know how to dress you don't wear
those Gucci ones may be a little too
tight on my on the old because you're
wearing they break in okay that leather
break yeah I don't you know what don't
[ __ ] your way no I will
no don't worry no I'm going to let's do
some I don't wear my povery sent us
attacks that drove me pretty nuts and
also only kicked off your liar you're a
goddamn liar
since this taxane hey guys check out my
new Instagram post bring that [ __ ] up
chin yeah yeah bring it on say he's not
gonna have sex anymore hold on hold on
let's read it I know well let's read a
pose I don't know mmm cuz I want to get
into this yeah me too mmm
cuz I think you're insane yeah hey it's
his [ __ ] life you need some so
important to tell so needs better ideas
needed better ideas for a while well
we're awesome alright here it goes
I've been in constant need of better
world dot dot dot I'm giving up sex
period indefinitely definitely now hold
on first of all you 14,000 people that
like this can suck my dick
it says no my G I didn't get hacked
be funny if you did I love sex I'm not
an addict to it but I
but it's a single biggest thing that is
homely back from serving my purpose to
causes me to party spend money catch a
cold and waste time guys call this
gadget cold yo yeah stay up and you do
[ __ ] you're not supposed to yeah right
now would be Brandon hey hey what dude
I'm gonna hurt you I'm supported on the
other front like you did last podcast
I'm just a liar fake I'm here to support
my friend on let's keep reading this uh
I've tried every right ship type except
this one so there's a reason for that so
here we go my goal six months my role is
I can't receive sexual pleasures from
anyone in cumin
take it easy Brett be supportive he's
keeping his diamond I've done this
letti but let's see how it goes any tips
or anyone out there lungs I've got us
three weeks and I had a wet dream at
Enid after eighteen days look when I
hold on hold on
first comment love this brother I've
been stilt the same practice deepen my
relationship to myself understand me my
connection to sex several times
similarly no sexual play full stop for
me for for me it was epic guys now look
at that support let's throw him in a
flying headlock I want to do like this
that guy as he's writing I want that
come out of nowhere
hey get on the ground he put long this
was about 12 months for me however the
body knows how to wet dream or two but
it was out of my hands you feel me
yeah that's a pretty way you're gonna
have some fun and gain deeper insights
into you that's interesting is it's
quite different to other sources of the
conscious expansion best of luck with
this my man a nice guy now here's the
thing all that's right that's that guy
I've been to the playground called the
onit studios or whatever the Aubrey
studios the Opry studios and there isn't
a flat ass to be found and by the way
but I don't die or desk looking guys and
gals I've ever seen people are working
out the green so enjoy that and good
luck I'm impressed
do you think the Buddha could have been
the Buddha if he didn't live in the
palace and first have all the feasts and
I like the way I like you too I'm saying
like not have to have abundance you
don't have abundance then you can I'm
the only reasonable one here dude
Buddhist fat he's not fat statue [ __ ]
booze fat no man he's a guru ma who
became the Buddha which means the
enlightened one was there like one was
not kita poor man he looked food
he loved food he indulged in food so it
wasn't that disciplined well no he did
live on a cup of rice tried today
because no I got 90 moderation so he
eats moderation wasn't shredded you ate
all that wasn't shredded all the food
God you don't know that this isn't about
you where did this come from okay so
this there's a couple different things
one if I can open relationship for one
is an amazing thing that I think
everybody should try but at will it's
almost guaranteed not to work but it's
worth it that's important to dial it on
for a second it's [ __ ] really try
worth it I tried like really hard
doesn't work and I think you've learned
a lot about yourself and you grow and
you become a better person
but the problem is is that it's almost
impossible to execute continually
because the thing is is that novelty of
the new person creates this thing what
the science calls limerence which is
this new relationship energy where you
become temporarily obsessed with the new
person that you're seeing for you so
you're in this relationship with someone
that you love dearly and then they find
somebody else it's not just calling
obsessed with them right and that thing
is almost impossible it's it is your way
you take almost how that sounds yeah so
like no matter how much you know them
how much love you share how long you've
been with them like they'll find some
new person and that new person whoever
that is will be the obsession of their
mind
of their body of their life for a little
while and I've been the person who've
been obsessed and then my partner's been
the person who's been obsessed
so that thing in and of itself is almost
impossible to transcend and I think it
is possible but you have to get to such
a state I don't know why it's all these
egos yeah no I'm saying there is a
possibility to be committed to the
person but then to say I'm not gonna try
to control that person's behavior in any
way like sort of like it's sort of like
whatever you do you're gonna do and I
can't stop you anyway so whatever
fulfills you but there's a way to sort
of will donate though yeah I don't want
to be with anyone who's gonna be [ __ ]
dudes on the road right I do you but
also don't [ __ ] your video but yeah but
also you talk about swingers that
usually works no no I'm just talking
about I'm just I'm up being in a
situation where you try not to control
someone's behavior right I don't think
you should I don't think you should own
someone sexuality but the problem is
when you open the door to sexuality you
open the door to this thing which is
this mental obsession with the new its
obsession though I think I think that's
I think there's a biology to it right I
agree I think that we evolved to the
fact that you do catch diseases if
you're not careful and I think there's a
there's an inherent intuitive natural
need for possession because it's very
dainty it historically was very
dangerous for your pardon to go off
because well not only they might go off
and shack up and leave you with the
children you can't provide for them you
starve to death during the winter or
whatever it might they might get a
disease and bring it back to you there's
so many there's so many physical dangers
traditionally historically that were
always clear and present and I feel like
that's also part of our deal but in our
touching a man's DNA isn't it it's in
our DNA to spread our see that's also
true but the in certain tribal settings
right where you have a tribe underneath
the Dunbar number of 150 right which is
about how tribes split up yeah within
that tribe it was more about tribe
survival than singular survival and
our number is explained that two kids
are really cool yeah after that yeah
yeah the Dunbar number is basically the
amount of people that you can give a
[ __ ] about yes at any given time is
about one yes it's about 150 give or
take right and so tribes always split to
about that amount but when the tribe was
more important than the singular
individual which is I think how we're
actually design and I think it's a big
problem that we have right now we don't
have that sense of community but within
that you see structures of relationship
where people didn't really care about
who the father was or what the what the
dyad what didn't what the couple bond
was because it was all about the
survival of the tribe itself but however
if someone went outside of the tribe
well that was [ __ ] war yeah because I
don't give a [ __ ] about anybody outside
of your Dunbar number the problem with
open relationship now is it's not within
your tribe it's not the people you uh
yeah way easier when it's someone you
love I've been in that situation where
someone I'm with is with somebody I love
and it's actually really chill I
actually to be completely honest that's
like a guy like both of you guys but
especially like a dude like him or like
if if my girl if I all [ __ ] aside my
girl wanted to like step out with my boy
when my brother I'd be like you know it
was way better but when it's some [ __ ] I
think when it's some [ __ ] yeah who
let me die some what bro you touch my
girl heavy eyes cool with it I guess I'm
a man do you heard it I guess I am yeah
but so they so you went down such a you
went you went so hard in the paint on
the salacious so hard in the paint and
the problem is it wasn't within the
tribe it was these random [ __ ]
Yahoo's yeah I didn't even know yeah it
didn't contribute
yeah just coming in and then the my
partner would be obsessed with with that
the first boy the new the new thing and
I didn't know this [ __ ] so he
was in my DNA he was outside of the
tribe so my inclination is not to be
like oh that's my brother and we're all
in this thing together no
all supporting each other we're all
helping us to yeah better it's like no
he's [ __ ] taking something that's
mine and I want to stab him in the
throat I remind my tell me that one
thing that haunted me those haunting I
was like - I was backed up yeah
haunting all right so many ways but
through that process there's also a lot
of beauty a lot of growth and a lot of
experience room and I got to I've
obviously got to experience an abundance
of my own sexual adventures women in the
world
that's all so thank you brother I
appreciate that they are beautiful women
and beautiful in a lot of ways you know
and yeah and I got to experience this
kind of level of abundance and in truth
in that as well like I never had to hide
anything and I was free to just do
whatever I like but nonetheless so it
was a combination of abundance plus the
combination of those repeated just
punches in the gut from the people that
I eventually you know always had
feelings for getting obsessed with other
people that so that whole thing was like
I needed to kind of put a stop to that
whole adventure and that was one of the
reasons why I was like wow I really want
to I really want to take a break where
I'm not actually even available or open
to these type of sexual connections
because I need to give myself a [ __ ]
just a [ __ ] breather yeah you know
it's just like taking a break from
sparring you're just like I got I might
have CTE yeah and my [ __ ] yeah and my
inside me you know I think you're
addicted to it I'm sure I like some of
the drama and the swings and the
up-and-down like that's like a it's an
endogenous chemical cocktail that comes
in when you feel those feel those things
and you train also the competition right
because I'm always competing to be the
best dick and be the one that [ __ ] them
the best and then get their attention
back oh you have attention to this other
guy well let me show you how [ __ ] bad
I am and you'll [ __ ] forget about
them but they don't forget about them
but you keep trying you keep reaching
that's your rock that's kind of a rock
it is it's very exciting but it's
addictive it makes your dick a little
harder to no doubt yeah it's called
reclamation sex so they come back from
this other guy and you're there with
them and you're like who well you were
with this other guy well watch this time
for some punishment
daddy's got a remark his territory now
that guy's got a bigger dick I'm gonna
crawl him in the corner and cry but the
point is this you try to get in their
head
whatever whatever whatever it takes so
it was not only what I'm what I'm
basically telling you is this took so
much time and energy and effort not only
in the in the maintenance of things but
in the competition of things an
emotional reconciliation it became part
of your quality work I'm actually
shocked that I accomplished anything
over the last six years it's really
actually remarkable yeah but I was able
to do anything yeah because the amount
of energy expenditure I had was just out
of control
so finally like I knew I knew at some
point I had to hit pause to like get
everything reconciled in an order and
the interesting that you talk this way
because if you think of any of the great
wisdoms any philosophy I don't I've read
a lot of philosophy I've read a lot
about religions I've read most of the
main major manuscripts and religion I
don't know of a religion I don't know of
a philosophy that can hold water that
advocates maybe you could marry make the
army with Nietzsche but for the most
part they all advocate some form of self
restriction some form a lot of it's not
yeah if not it's not monogamy certainly
certainly well none of us are in sexual
conservatism to an extent right because
they can't encourage or one's gone
there's a deeper there's a deeper truth
to it which is you've made a lot of
these guys whether it was Thomas Aquinas
whether it was who wrote confessions
please look up confessions I'm sorry
it's a very important book but a lot of
people who went off and did that came
back to Augustine st. Augustine
one of the founders of the church
McCambridge Servat ISM it feels like
that's kind of where you're headed and I
think it's interesting that most people
that go that direction if they're honest
which you are will chamber hold my beer
and chefs
no but that's that's true but they
really every celebrity I know everything
sports play I know goes I'm getting it
but you know what a lot of celebrities
do that I've noticed too is that they go
crazy and then they're in
Hey a lot of that this town is so full
of Stauber pure for now because they
went so crazy but it's a similar
pleasure principle I feel like but the
bottom line is that a lot of people's
you get older you start to try it you
try to start a circle back to and you
understand why these wisdoms
advocate that whether it's yoga whether
it's Buddhism whether it's Catholicism
whether it I have to believe that since
they're still relevant and they have a
lot to offer that there's some deep
wisdom there I don't think you I think
one of the things that they don't talk
about which is a failure is I think you
have to actually get to abundance before
you can let it go there you go right
like a lot of people I think maybe a lot
of people who are talking about these
you know path of restrictions and this
you know path of abstaining from this
thing and that maybe couldn't get that
like hello let's let's not worry about
wealth well they couldn't get wealthy so
they just made it like oh you don't need
that so it wasn't real because if they
actually had the chance to get wealthy
they would I don't think you can
transcend the desire for wealth unless
you're wealthy I don't think you can
transcend the desire for success unless
you've been successful and I don't think
you can let go of sex unless you've had
a radical abundance of sex yeah to the
point where you can be like okay okay
okay like I got this you know what it is
I know what it is and I felt it I've
experienced all the things I can let it
go I'm not letting it go forever it
sounds like you though we're talking
about this difference so in the Bible of
just to take an example it's not the
love of money that's the root of all
evil
it's I'm sorry it's not the money that's
rid of all the actual quarters it's the
love of money mmm so you know you were
being controlled a little bit it was
taking up a large part of your psyche in
your energy did you hit rock bottom um
[ __ ] robbed out I puck and got
dribbled off that like I was a [ __ ]
basketball that's what would be rocking
down girl that's well that was the highs
right so if you imagine a basketball
bouncing off rock bottom and then going
up flying up sky or maybe one of those
super bouncy balls right so those are
super super high the lows are super low
cuz it is you find that new person you
have this new experience and it is the
chase and the thrill and even with the
same person you get these super highs of
Reclamation wow this is so incredible
we're back together like everything
feels electric and alive and then you
get the super lows so it's this
this bounce of fact no that was just
kind of constant instead of this just
general band of equanimity and meas
we're like ah now let me look at what I
can do in my life that actually is going
to be the most productive almost letting
things come to you maybe yeah in in and
also I think this for me is just like
this is just a little bit of a hard stop
no [ __ ] way I'm gonna give up sex
nobody for a long time but like my goal
is six months I got a book manuscript do
then that takes a lot of time anyways
dude one step at one day at a time one
time five days to do today listen I'm
five days it we don't talk to him but
here we do six months let's get through
sunny day and take it from I can six
months is it's you like your bill you're
going at the top of the mountain
climbing average drawing at the top of
the mountain no let's get the take up
steps have some tea
couple biscuits talk it's talk still
feel good so feel good line the next
line little bit more good night
you just went well that's why I said my
goal right you know and I said
indefinitely I don't know exactly when
it's my goal is roughly six months I
don't know don't look up but Thursday
here's a question I have for you guys so
my rule that I put out is I'm not going
to have sexual pleasure for myself but
I'm wondering if I can still have hope
people sit on my face know the answer
the answer to me is well the answer to
me is 100% I would say Wayfarers you
guys do it you got to just get away from
all of it because you're still suits
kind of in the hustle over basically the
question is can I have one and only four
glasses at night there's no way a girl
sitting on my face and I'm not gonna
have to have sex we're still in the pool
bro pool get out of the pool see I
didn't want to hear that answer but I
think you're right rope slash you're a
girl fat night right
Gaming jackoff get out there we go she's
gonna reach for your piece and she's
gonna go let me put in my mouth and then
you're gonna go okay but I'm not gonna
come eat I'm only gonna come in their
mouth that's not in the bargaining
starts and then the gradual slide dude
get out the pool what you do is you do
this you have my face there my face no
but I have an older wrinkly guy whose
face you can sit on you're grateful
enthusiastic and he's got a piece on and
I can't even wear it off a mask yeah and
look it's be afraid of film it your
family I'm gonna feel good about it
anyway we're that awesome come on and
that goddamn awesome and your boy a
little bit big boy film it send it to
you all right so you get all right and
then we sing you the videos pretty good
I like the idea all right if you're if
you listen you know hey you know what
man also think about this one time
somebody is crazy look let me tell you a
story about this one time so I'm 21
years old I'm going to LA foam which is
a burlesque show at the MGM Grand I
don't know if anybody saw but it's based
off the Crazy Horse in Paris you guys
bring up picture of the Crazy Horse in
person it's like the most beautiful
girls I've ever seen in my life and I'll
show you here because there's a Crazy
Horse in Vegas right that's that's a
strip club but this is like this is the
Paris one so pick a like the girls in a
lineup any one of those girls and the
girls in the lineup so basically they're
all like this same perfect body and they
wear wigs and there's light and there's
stuff like this and there's this
dazzling experience I'm 21 I'm by myself
I'm full I'm sipping this whiskey and in
tears start to well up a - I'm still in
college I haven't accomplished anything
and I can't even [ __ ] get any of the
girls that I want her in college because
they're already out with like no finals
and like I've no money I've no nothing
so I'm sitting there and I'm like I'm
going to do and be the type of person
that could date any one of these girls
the type of person that these girls
would love no matter what it [ __ ]
takes that means mentally physically
spiritually financially in every way and
it was like this deep solemn vow it
sounds like a seminal traumatic moment
it was a moment where I come back I have
and it's incredible I've been to the one
that could had fun oh yeah been well not
with the girls but I went back to watch
a show I've never actually gotten with
one of these actual girls but I've
gotten with the equivalent of so but
that moment was like that that was like
a that was part of my dry it's been my
drive since that moment at 21 is like
I'm gonna be the best version of myself
in all ways possible get these girls so
I could get that situation this
situation that's so insanely powerful
when you're a young man and my
experience at 21 in Paris was very
similar to that very similar where I saw
these women at a club I went to this the
hippest Club I had never seen it was so
overwhelming because I beautiful my
father my dad bought all of them is a
great yes my father I'm sorry that
feeling of them being out of touch out
of reach yeah and then now let's varsity
blues over here varsity blues didn't
have that issue did you like a buff hero
right you were like no I've never had a
problem there's certain things like hot
girls you know if they're ours and cars
will do that for me you know you have a
love for finer things in life
yes I was out of touch for a while yes
yeah it was it was it was women and it's
been the motivation from my entire life
and everything that I do has a little
bit of that in it you know a lot of the
things I do is is pure like I'm purely
doing this for the good of all and I'm
you're a good person you're an honest
[ __ ] but you know there's always
some in most everything in every workout
every [ __ ] thing I accomplish every
time I put something out when I write a
book I think about maybe a girl like
this reading that book like every little
bit of huh yeah every little bit of what
I've done has had some part of this as a
motivation I don't think you're alone
Aubrey and I don't think that's rare you
know a makes you a bad person no I think
it's I think it's all class who said
that Picasso said men go to war fight
bulls paint do everything for a woman
like if sex you know I mean at the so
did Freud yeah and it's it's really no
to Darwin it's really it's really kind
of true but I'm curious and this is
another thing it's like maybe factor
three but I'm also I'm curious what
happens if I take that off the table and
like what am i what do I really care
about do I really care about lifting
weights the same way or do I want to do
more yoga or do i or do I really or do I
really love lifting weights like I love
and I think I do
Oh interesting I think I do but maybe I
don't see a lot of time don't you think
a lot of guys want to be big because the
other due to two reasons I think one is
wanted to be attractive to to the
opposite sex or the same sex depending
and and the second is this is certainly
for me certainly for me being able to
defend myself in an emergency down
inside of me deep down inside of me and
I think all men feel this way I feel
like I ultimately I need to be a little
bit ready because I'm going to have to
fight for my life eventually in some
aspect yeah whether I get a disease
whether I don't wake up and train and
think about that but though but a lot of
guys in the gym I feel like a lot of
time when the guys are real big they're
not doing that for this no that's
emotional armor yeah I think there's a
lot of reason for me it for me it has
largely been for chicks and also for
competition and also I trained enough
that I'm feel confident in like the
streets or any situation like that I'm
not like a great fighter but was the
endorphins yeah the endorphins there's a
lot of reasons but the real question is
the real question is this is so weird to
me I thought a lot about this the amount
of time I spend at 52
doing jujitsu
well I smell just recently but I doing
this like I'm I just came from Higa
Machado's school I'm practicing armbar
and I'm practicing guillotine it's very
relaxing to me because I feel like ah
good rounding off those edges in case
there's a situation at least I can at
least I'm not an idiot it's been a long
time since I've grappled and I now check
that off I'm grappling again in boxing
so these are things I this sounds crazy
you feel safer are you enjoyed doing I
do love the arm maybe you felt unsafe of
course I was moved to [ __ ] eternal
world and you always get bullied like a
frog you said that you were built like
the WB frog I'm saying I don't like the
way you're [ __ ] to know your finger
don't touch my finger don't invade my
fur WB frog listen I have good genetic
you do a beep I feel so sick so sick
this entire episode but what I was
saying though is you weren't like gifted
with size and stuff so I'm assuming me
yes for real I felt you lead around all
the time yes I always felt unsafe and
then never I still grew up kind of
chaotic too right no not at all actually
my [ __ ] was calm way offerin my [ __ ] was
call you know I mean my my parents split
and like my dad had it my dad's had
anger like anger issues and stuff hit
you I was no but I was always I was
always big enough and athletic enough
and I also started training like martial
arts when I was like looking for and
what you really get a basketball I was
really good at basketball and most of
the sports really basketball was what I
focused on but I was a good athlete i
training martial arts tiles for this guy
I was actually the funny thing my my
first martial arts coach was actually
the referee and Karate Kid one his
name's Pat Johnson that's [ __ ] it is
he was really cool he was great and so I
knew enough that I always felt confident
so for me your six to that that was
never that was never really part of the
motivation but the thing is even though
I was like a
skeeball star I don't think I ever got
the girl I actually wanted until I was
like I don't know man like 24 yeah but
have you girl you want him like oh this
is the perfect one no no no talking
about this this morning cars I don't
know why I can't get a car where I'm
just like oh good oh this is it man um
this is the exact car but I don't know
what it is oh yeah that's this one I was
like I don't yeah I don't I don't know
what it is man I thought this would be
the car I get it six months like do you
feel like you're missing out or
something no but I mean you have to get
that other car what is it no cuz you
have the best car they're awesome
I want this other car now then I'm like
oh and I told my brother like hopefully
this is the one no I stopped no it won't
be it's called hedonic tolerance right
like reach will hedonic tolerances as
soon as you get used to the pleasure of
something it no longer becomes
pleasurable and it's something that's in
every single human being and that's why
what it's exciting the excitement is
going to fade and this is why in open
relationships you get fucked-up
relationship with my cars yeah your
relationship with your car's you get
used to it then you don't obsess with
the new one and then you don't even give
a [ __ ] about your old one anymore and if
your car had emotions your cars crush I
kick my fryer today
hey what don't kick you know I kicked it
I'm sick of it I'm obsessed with this
gt2 RS British green one your mind bring
that [ __ ] out it's in your head dude
think about the British green if you
could all the time you'd be sending it
that's it wow that's a nice car that's a
Porsche it's the best car it's the best
car I don't know dude it's a British
racing drag this car you can get why do
you why Brendan cuz I sit in traffic on
the 405 did I oh yeah anybody man you
have probs huh I don't know I just tell
my brother I don't know fights sometimes
it could be a trauma thing my buddy I
had this crazy I had this crazy
intervention with my body right so my
friend had was only he would only have
sex with hookers and his his he would
pay for them and the goal was to get
them to like him to the point where he
didn't have to pay them anymore
oh oh and by the way when it got crazy
said there's a service ID
nobody goes van picks me up down on Wall
Street and if there's a mattress and you
have sex with her as they're driving you
home
yeah let's guys he's hot as [ __ ] he's
dead cold I'm the last one the basil I
don't know I want one of the best one of
the best one of the best one of the
greatest of all time but we had a long
talk he got over it subsequently he got
over it took him a long time but we had
to talk one time when I said what is it
he said I don't trust women I said what
what happened he said uh you may set a
name like for Mary Johnson for the story
I go wide he goes I was in love with her
in high school and I was driving by and
she was on the side of the road cuz her
car had broken down and she was my
girlfriend
and I looked and she was the car the
tire was being changed by whatever his
name was who was the cab in the football
team at the time Ilya with apparently
had a piece on him to you
Travis you have a chance tired I can't I
can't compete with that guy and also I
don't blame her and also that's the end
of relationships cuz that can always
happen to me it's never gonna happen
nice cool thank you yeah but that should
deepen bad cars hit you that's when
you're young yeah when you're young
that's when you're the most pliable
well [ __ ] like it's funny when [ __ ] can
hit you right like I caught I gotta I'm
one of the girls I've seen I caught her
sending a naked naked [ __ ] photo to
hurt my mother dudes in front of me and
I was like Italy spoiled what
oh no hander face Oh
you're a bit of a sharpener not reading
the room you better sharpen planet
because you're playing a mile I planted
sex can I have it on the side you get it
here give me another instrument give it
a viola plays outside Paul take this
viola and take it easy and wait that
would have hurt my feelings it's good
though they sewed that thing that thing
it leaves a mark it leaves them I mean
it's not like it changed it dramatically
changed my life like your friend who's
in the hooker vans you know yeah yeah I
don't and I don't know if people I talk
to are be especially fun you know I'm
trying to figure something out with like
yeah I don't know what it is why I'm not
trying make this about me I don't know
what it is what I'm just not happy with
certain things like though those
material things whether it shoes is
reason why over 200 shoes there's a
reason why I have the house is reason I
go through cars there's something there
but none of its what she has I get older
none of that fills any you know there's
no that smell is there yeah and it's
like whatever venue I play whether I
sell to Wilbur that there's always that
the what do you think that do you like
there it is no it's just always a weird
thing but I can trace my things back to
one eighth grade where these girls
including my girlfriend we're talking
about how my buddy is so sexy and a
t-shirt well I didn't know girls talk
this race you guys and it just ripples
when you see it and one girl goes uh-huh
you know and she went and I went I I
don't
wait hold on stop everything you don't
rip hold on I don't ripple and also how
come you girls are sexually into that
yeah and also how do I become well that
never turned out for me so I got funny
and then I got bullied when I was uh it
the year before that and for a whole
year buy a real son of a [ __ ] and I
remember like I was like I remember
saying to myself don't that's never
gonna happen to me never like there's
nobody in the planet that could bully me
you can try but don't go to sleep I'm
gonna get ya know I'm gonna gay you hear
me mail created the adaptation
right now those things go ahead but you
have to track there must have been some
point where you felt like in scarcity of
the ability to get the car you wanted or
scarcity of the ability to get the shoes
you wanted we couldn't come see maybe
your feet were too big and you just
[ __ ] you'd go to you go to Foot
Locker and they wouldn't have size 14s
and you'd have to get some shitty little
pair of shoes there's no [ __ ] like that
I don't know I'm just hypothesizing some
scenario but probably there was some way
in which you didn't get that thing you
wanted and you thought oh I might
because he would have fat kid I was a
nice clothes he gave you the saxophone
and now you're [ __ ] fat yeah I don't
know I don't maybe you're gay but did
you always get the car you wanted when
you're in high school and stuff was like
you did you have the car that you
thought like when you know I know and
did that bother you no I never thought
about oh so when you're like oh you are
great now not bad I was like so focus on
sports I think growing up like my dad
set high values on cars like we'd go to
every car show okay we'd go up to all
the it might be our shows there's a
difference it might be a passion is not
unhealthy so so could be you know some
people have just a passion for certain
things and I do think you have a passion
for cars Rogen does too I don't think
that having a passion for something like
that is a mark of psychological scarring
sometimes it's just what I have a
passion for women that's actually
healthy yeah you know and like I think
we all do it's not and I think you
obviously have a passion for cars and
shoes that's actually healthy but
probably going to those car shows and
having over and over looking at cars
that you couldn't [ __ ] but we can in
fact you couldn't even get him is like
wow they be right can't be helped off
but I can even I can't even touch this
thing weird and somehow that got in your
subconscious like on one day I'm gonna
be that [ __ ] that can go our
show girls for you and factly
I'm gonna be that [ __ ] they're
gonna go to that car show and I can open
that velvet robe and say I'll take that
one yeah interesting
Carson drew also look at cars you look
at cars differently than that
someone like I do on and you look at a
[ __ ] Porsche you're looking at the
engineering you're looking at the the
paint you're looking at all the details
the the the the artistry in the chassis
you would go like the my guy Greg
climber who's my car guy yeah I met I
met Greg yeah cool just he gets cars for
Canelo Mayweather so he looks all over
the world and I said I need this
specific gt2 this color rims this kind
of intere this color this this it's just
so it's a package and they only make
certain ones and it's just he'll send
pictures like no this is off this is off
even he's like Jesus Christ dude I don't
know if we're gonna find this one and
then for me I'm probably gonna have the
same car for the rest of my life like
here I crashed my Tesla I know I got the
same exact one with the same exact wrap
and the same exact interior and if I
please I hope I do not want to crash
this one that was not fun but let's say
something happens this car I'll get the
[ __ ] same one I might wrap it a
different color you know something like
that but like I'm gonna don't care I
don't care I text my brother swear I'm
like God sometimes I wish we didn't care
about this stuff
and he's like why you think if you enjoy
it who gives a [ __ ] it's not like you're
not it's not like you're not feeding
your kid to buy a Porsche or a bike you
know what would she would have would
have changed that if I actually thought
that the cars wouldn't affect the girls
but I realize like early on that the
cars don't affect the girls but actually
a little bit the shoes kind of do so
like I guess all the thought I kind of
have like I've got a lot of good kicks
to like yeah you should my reason is
mostly because like girls will see the
shoes like nice shoes and I'll be like
oh that's the [ __ ] that's the thing
that I need is you know it's weird and I
don't really care about I know girls
care about clean shoes and like nice
shoes I've never once bought a shoe for
it's only for other sneaker heads it's
only for other dudes well you also like
shoes love is part of the things it's
more of you love expression yeah but you
love fashion you [ __ ] you do love
clothing and then again that's to me
that's a little bit more of a of a
cultivated sort of eye for something
it's kind of the same way somebody likes
painting or swallowing like you like
yeah I love wine cuz I just I love
everything about what it takes to make a
great wine like
like using cars objects likes chicks
really yeah chicks and then putting out
ideas to the world me Brian loves this
don't get it twisted yeah but no we're
not like oh I'm not kind of sores maybe
I mean we're not affection out of that
was that was it that was my thing you
have to party I looked at Brendan we
went to one of his party so I was like
well this is Snoop Dogg video it was so
crazy I went pants
see ya I was like I was like hey where's
when do we take the sex break because
this is an old big boy sir crunk in a
car after a DMT session you know the DMT
I couldn't figure out why I was crying
like that for Tim Kenny I love Tim loved
one my favorite people on earth but he
didn't want him to double I was crowd I
was I didn't want him to die and go back
to war I'm talking about I'm talking to
my wife at the time he's dude I've ever
heard ass I've ever cried I think behind
his and then I couldn't figure out like
why am i crying I've never the beard was
in the backseat I was like Evan let's go
back in there I walked in here he was
the dmt I forgot we did DMT gonna be a
little late he's got allergies he's
crying
oh I was I mean dude all right that was
you trying to tell me a good cry feels
nice it does feel no you had a great
experience man I remember you just
laughing when that when that when that
chrysanthemum of divine light just
transcended and poured through the top
of your head and just started paint you
just started laughing cuz it's so
beautiful that there's no other response
that actually make there's nothing so
hard man like dude what do you think of
like the joke same thing man
DMT pens I think I was a little
skeptical so like people shouldn't be
doing these out in public and I still
believe that but if you do the DMT pens
in the same type of ceremony that we did
it is the [ __ ] way to go because for
one it's not going to burn your lungs
for two if you're actually in control of
your own pen you can reach the level of
DMT load that you want and then you can
keep sipping on the pen and stay there
oh so it feels like you're getting
contact with what I call what they call
the doctor see toes with little doctors
right these little doctors of light that
are like mint like fixing you it feels
like they're fixing you or they're
teaching you or they're talking to you
about something or showing you something
but with DMT normally it goes in this
curve and then
just slips away slips away so fast but
if you have the pen you just keep
sipping the pen it also felt like up in
the pen you can stay there where do I
get that pen yeah we get these but I
also felt like I felt like I was there
for a while
and that's how long was that you're like
that was like a minute yeah but it felt
like I was in this gold heaven and like
floating it is the greatest thing I've
ever done it's really [ __ ] special I
did the MT and I came out gay yeah I
don't know it was weird man there was a
guy who can antidepressant and then had
an effect on his brain where he he was a
family man with kids and he started
[ __ ] not true is that a lie well he's
gay man blamed on having heavy sex with
strangers in bathroom hey stop taking
the pills bro
he sued in my head hook that up he sued
and won it was an antidepressant man he
was a family man and just started
[ __ ] guys I believe he's gay as well
he blamed mark imagine the waters later
on you gay I was like went over E and
blamed horse meat yeah sighs yeah I had
a 6-inch sub and I love chicks and big
titties he sure was adding a presence or
something else I don't think that's I
don't think that's particularly real I
think it actually reveals people get
really worried it's in strike people get
worried yeah yeah man claims Parkinson's
turn him into a gay cells had a few gay
bro
51 man has been taking yep I think he's
fully shut though how about the game and
blamed it on the [ __ ] drugs yeah
nothing wrong it's be gay dude you
should know that some of the people who
took medications are just rope Rin role
developed gambling problems or other
intense urges or behavior that were
compulsive or unusual for them such as
increased sexual urges or behaviors
there is enough information to tell
whether the people developed these
problems because they took the
medication or for other reasons call
your doctor if you have an urge to
gamble that is difficult even though you
have intense urges or control
doesn't mean it changes right now what
are you doing right now now cuz I'm but
I got a sock I got a sack bro took my
medication I get a that's great only six
hundred and ten grand damages why the
ten grand just six hundred there should
be no damages just be like enjoy being
gay yeah you're welcome yeah you know
whatever like it's fine you know why why
why is it a bad thing yeah you know he's
going hard in the paint now I mean I'm
proud of him he's our boy Jason Ellis
yeah you say yeah I do it's a cage says
bye right totally bye he told kids right
yeah yeah talk to him about it he's just
he's just enjoying what he enjoys like
and he doesn't feel guilty about it and
he doesn't feel ashamed about it you
don't know anyone I give a [ __ ] I don't
care I really care that's what he wants
to do that's the that's the healthy
approach and I think that's the that's
the place that we're getting to where
you don't even really worry about it you
think we're getting there I think we are
I think I mean I think it's a rocky road
where people are like overreacting on a
lot of different things but I think
ultimately we're gonna get to a place
where you don't really look at stuff
like that with any form of judgment it's
like oh you're gay or whatever like you
don't need to proclaim it I think we're
in this I think a lot of us realize
science has started to show that those
kinds of things are not something that
that there's no and even if they [ __ ]
did yeah cares but like right now it's
like it's right now you have to like
clean mail you out of the closet or all
this things because of the repression
and the shame the repression and shame
created reaction and now the reaction is
creating this this kind of thing that's
happening and all of this is healthy and
necessary but ultimately it's just gonna
be like yeah whatever
yeah whatever and nobody's gonna like
nobody's gonna really care either way
unless you're in Russia Russia's [ __ ]
it's all day really stay in that clock
you get beat up
they don't play there as well sometimes
Russia Russia is a very conservative
country and a very religious country the
cut the government is not religious but
but Russians in general are tend to be
very religious they're Orthodox
Christian and and so there's there's
it's a very religious play no games yeah
they've had a very traumatic history
there's still a patriarchy Jews most of
the people going out on these gay like
raids like the pogroms that they used to
do act like
are gay so that's the thing they're
bashing the gay out of themselves a and
doing another person so many remotes are
so many like senators who who throw you
know our congressmen who pushed for this
anti-gay legislation they get caught
trying dudes in some bathroom like that
senator that's that's always the case
there's not a big gay movement in Asia
either right kind of frowned upon again
China's intense I would say Thailand
it's pretty right so I mean but in Japan
and Korea Korea it's frowned upon
yeah sure yeah Korea's very conservative
yeah and very male-dominated and stuff
but but all these things have their
Underground's and all these things are
finding there all right there is a there
is an LGBTQ sort of presence in Russia
there just and there did they fight for
our rights but the problem is sometimes
you can't get they can't get apartments
they can't get jobs they're all he's
like Swissy riot was that right and
[ __ ] Riot got thrown in prison okay
their people got pissed but and I think
that's the way it has to go you like
rebel against this these ideas and so
that brings a lot of energy and it
brings a lot of anger and and I think it
starts the the process and said huden
said he made a speech about him he said
we have a very casual attitude towards
this he said but if you could just leave
students in peace and not cram the if
they could just learn reading writing
and arithmetic and the basics first
before we start taking you know
elementary school kids and middle school
kids and tell them about how you can be
a man or a woman and how you can be and
I think that's that's where some of the
push back in Russia came from to where
the the the movement was taking a page
from the United States and pushing into
ed the educational circles and stuff so
look when it depends these are all look
in the absence of education there's the
internet yeah there's the [ __ ]
Internet look look at your little
[ __ ] art piece right there like
that's Peter Pan much and pull your pan
watching porn that great and like
everybody who has a role like you've
never realized that I can never read my
favorite piece of art all right that's
cried but that's it is great because you
know why because of all the little Peter
Pan's it
you got like if you got give your kid a
smartphone they're watching porn
I wanted a warning but a really good one
that's a real painting that's good we
I've that that see spider-man it's it's
like superheroes doing real [ __ ] so Spy
Randy taking a breaking cheeseburger
it's great I got Robocop around here
drinking oil like it like a beer and I
think there's one more in there yeah I
forgot what it but it's not over there
oh it's Mario shaving who's your who's
yours Picasso look into it okay yeah
check that that's actor but yeah but if
we don't educate if we don't educate in
a sensible way about drugs about sex
about all of these different things and
people just [ __ ] look it up and then
they'll just like get their all their
ideas from that thing so their
bachelor's degree on the Internet
exactly which is which which is a
problem you know and and people who are
avoiding those conversations it just
creates dissonance with their kids it
creates dissonance like information yeah
just like if you you want to be the
person that your kid can come to when
they're like hey so I read about this
type of drug and you want to be like
okay well let me tell you about that and
let me tell you like when it's really
bad idea to do it and let me tell you
when it might be okay but it's probably
not a good time now you know and like so
you want to be able to have that
sensible conversation but I have your
kid be able to come to you or if they're
like curious about some crazy different
type of sex or they're starting to get
like a a fetish of some sort be like all
right like I get it like you know be
able to be that person that your kids
can talk to about it rather than them
just go into the internet and down this
rabbit hole wondering if they're weird
and being ashamed of themselves and
being felt strange you know like be
there and that's the same with friends
anything on Cambridge Santa Monica the
the company that was essentially helped
the Trump administration win the
election and what the whistleblower who
worked there said he said what they were
doing it be he said it was the
equivalent of when you meet somebody
who's really awesome and they seem
amazing I know so much about you and you
have the same exact interests and you
have this amazing dinner and this being
do who you don't realize is they been
walking you and studying you for a year
and so they know exactly how to talk to
you alone
he said cameras down I would do this
they would get your profile and they
would figure out everything you want to
do it and then they would feed you
information you wanted to know this
probably the internet let's faith
they've they feed you all the
information that that all you already
agreed with and then they put you
together with communities like that and
then they'd sponsor events where you'd
go to a coffee shop in 50 100 other
people and we're speaking like and
pretty soon you start to think not only
that that's the reality because that's
how everybody's talking in your world
but then you start to think then they
start floating things like how the
mainstream media is lying and don't want
you to know it so all of a sudden you go
well I'm getting the real info no but
what's really happening is Cambridge
analytic a it's curating that
information and sending it to you damn
and and this whistleblower was like what
I realized this was so wrong yeah and so
so the Internet is that man it's like if
you like just right I'm looking those
gt2 RS is if I up my phone now and go
looking for shoes I'll get something
that pops up of a Porsche or something
to remind me I'll remember this remember
their yeah whatever you lee it'll pop up
you look at you groceries on that whole
foods are you pop your data is sold and
resold and resold your data is is out
there yeah people are people are
stalking us and for our money and for
anything that we might want to buy you
know or anything that might even capture
our attention because then if they
capture our attention then they can
serve ads to us about anything else so
like every little thing that's is
designed to keep us on there longer like
even the algorithms on Instagram like
the algorithms are rewarding people for
pausing on on the scroll of the feed
because that means that they're gonna be
taking longer to get through their
scroll so like everything is designed to
just keep you there that's also like you
know so a lot of criminals a lot of like
people businessmen who want to do really
secretive stuff they have and they
instead of texting on regular app texts
on something like signal right flip
phone but there are apps like signal
where it goes away it's like sighs dude
guess what though guess who invented a
Russian dude and you're not going here
right you know where that's going you're
you're just giving somebody else all
your [ __ ] info and he's a Russian
entrepreneur okay
I don't know I'm buying that yeah you
know so you can't you can't I don't
think you can fight it I think you got
to internally fight it I think you got
to like have armed yourself for the
information and gird yourself with your
own like knowledge and an awareness
celibate dude and not having a fight
yeah that's that would be like going Ari
style and just get in the [ __ ] to get
the flip phone and like keeping it keep
it that's what he bakes a lot of the big
business boys aren't like Dana White has
flip phones like because they don't want
in your I don't blame so they flip
phones and they're not a big businessman
I flip phones because they don't want
you getting to hold like maybe I private
information is that why go into the
cloud okay so yeah don't put anything
else if you can hack into like if they
get your email through iTunes they
getting your iTunes they get to your
cloud then get delete pictures old
picture like tax so yeah a lot of money
taught these guys over everything don't
use a cloud it's my card storage yeah
yeah put it on their hard storage I'll
like I'll start fresh with a new phone
too
and like leave my file I'll leave my
phone and like it's safe you know so
like leave it in there and then I'll go
back to it if I need to there's some
good stuff on some of those old phones
you know you want you want to maybe go
back and be interviewed your history on
the show but nonetheless like start
[ __ ] fresh don't leave it all out
there hanging you know and that's just
that's just that's just hygiene in this
day and age it's just washing your hands
Fox just [ __ ] being clean or do that
I have that much tide but still it's
good at current events or current events
sometimes you need someone to talk to
and it's more than just a friend Brian
it's gotta be a professional sometimes
we talk to each other we get no we're
not running circles guys don't guys tell
me don't know it but what they do better
help better help is a service and app
where you can actually start
communicating in under 24 hours with a
licensed professional as professional
counselling done securely online there's
a broad range of expertise expertise and
better helps counselor network which may
or not be locally available in many
areas it's not a crisis line though
y'all it's not self-help it's a
professional counseling done securely on
alright did your counselor anytime you
want you get timely and thought
responses worldwide baby we worldwide
it's way more affordable than the
traditional offline counseling
you can also financial aid is even
available Brian that's pretty awesome
financial aid is available you can
schedule weekly or phone sessions and
video sessions as well which is really
helpful so you can actually see the
person I'd say video is the way to go I
think so yeah is it better help calm
slash fighter and join the over 500,000
people talking and taking charge of
their mental health all right finally
kid you guys get ten percent off your
first month at better help calm slash
fighter
I want socks that are comfortable that I
can rely on for the holidays it gets
cold in the holidays I want my feet warm
I said it I'm not compromising and I'm
sick and tired of having socks that tear
like mine well don't wear business socks
though every day I'll Janie and what am
I supposed to do supposed to wear bombas
bro wamba's the number one most
requested item alright and homeless
shelters is socks yeah I know alright
that's guess what bomber socks are
create has created a thing to change all
that for every pair you buy Obama's
donates a pair to someone in need now
they just don't give them any socks they
get bomba socks they're so dang soft not
just pretty soft I'm talking the softest
cotton in the world extra cushioning
where you need it bomba socks provides
support in places you didn't know you
needed you didn't know your arches yeah
man Oh a special arch support system
that's supportive but not too tight
dude give the gift that keeps on giving
oh you can someone's dogs take care of
your dogs and talk about your feet if
you want to give someone the perfect
gift these this holiday you want to give
them the perfect gift give them the
holiday bomba hold on I got that got
even better for you first of all hug
your feet but they got merino wool socks
now you're going briar why merino wool
socks if your feet get wet
god forbid and you're hiking you gotta
figure out hunting and doing man stuff
killing me feet stay warm with merino
wool the soft they're warm they're
natural naturally moisture wicking never
itchy or rough okay that's just not
they're not your grandfather's wool
socks got me
Adam go to bombas comm slash fighter
today and get 20% off your first
purchase that's Bo MBA s.com slash
fighter bombers comm slash by the sure
Bobby Marcus Kat those those chicken
sandwich you brought in
there's no way Popeyes or chick-fil-a
better there's no why do I need to try
them I mean hopefully you don't cuz some
guy died recently waiting in line for a
Popeye sandwich there was a dispute at
Maryland between two men one man said
that the other cut in line right before
him and they got into a verbal argument
which then led to one guy stabbing the
other a 28-year old man they don't
specify whether he was the one who cut
in line or the guy who was waiting in
line originally but he was rushed to the
hospital after getting stabbed a couple
of times and he actually passed away a
chicken sandwich damn does anyone ever
died over a McRib yeah it sounds like
you had two [ __ ] they had a that a
surplus and Mister mcribs that's why
dawns like there's a [ __ ] scarcity of
pop I didn't even got in the fight at
Costco Popeyes didn't matter although he
might have been hungry when you're
hungry but also here's the problem like
people like kids they have gotten
murdered or they got robbed and stabbed
for Jordans because there's such a
limited amount of them scarce people
yeah so people have like this urge like
oh I'm gonna miss out and then they kill
[ __ ]
yeah beanie babies Elmo yeah Jarrod
jiggle freaking out Jarrod's island is
there a diamond is the great he rode
comes germs and steel and he studies
indigenous cultures and he was up in a
Papua New Guinea where these tribes were
really isolated and they get along man
it's all good as long as they have
access to resources as soon as there is
a lack of water and one group has a
better control of that water the group
over here business very quickly starts
coming up with reasons they start making
up stories and coming up with reasons
why that group over there needs to die
yeah and he'll start speaking genocide
and and there are instances where this
tribe will come over there in the
highlands they've been isolated for
forty thousand years and they'll wipe
them all out like now they're in the way
we need water dude if I let this guy's
chicken see you can't give it you can't
listen chicken Sam I'll stab you over
chicken Sam these what weird ours are
from Hattie's no Howlin race Howlin
ready Hattie's where's that Chinatown
downtown LA is it is it a Asian no a
white guy opened it up
hell yeah yeah white what were you
telling me about cargo cults Brian no so
out in the South Pacific are not in the
South Pacific there would be cargoes of
supplies that would get dropped during
them like military operations and
sometimes they would get dropped in the
wrong spot and like indigenous people
would get like a cargo full of all kinds
of rad [ __ ] like rations MREs [ __ ]
all kinds of like whatever the [ __ ] send
all the cool [ __ ] lighters cigarettes
whiskey you know like everything that
the troops would want right click all
the good [ __ ] and then they would get
this random cargo in this random day and
then they would create this religion
around it and try to recreate the
circumstances of that day came down so
that another cargo like Jesus on top of
Yahoo something else would come down
from the sky and they would like pray to
the God Papa New Guinea was there always
happening though was it always getting
drop no it was just it would randomly
happen and it was such a great thing
that they developed a whole religion
around this great thing that happened
they gave him [ __ ] cigarettes and
whiskey and I stopped coming in yeah of
course it would stop coming it was an
accident they dropped it on the wrong
spot they're trying to give it to the
troops while all the sudden indigenous
people under Guinea when they took off
on a plane their anthropologist and they
came back they had the the [ __ ]
they were two pygmy the people I'd let
them turn on pygmies but there they were
like I want to be able to fly too we
want a hug so they recreated the entire
they had a runway they could they made a
plane they had the gun and they just
figured you know they didn't understand
propulsion or you know dynamics that
would they've been isolated for 40,000
years it was the same exact [ __ ]
thing they're nothing but did
they create a plane they create they
made a plan it was like well it was like
a stick like it was sir it wasn't it
wasn't me here but they just look like
it created enough if they created all
the same circumstances that the baby
might take off yes [ __ ]
the other thing is that in Haiti it's
imperative it's a fairly the Voodoo
there's a fairly religious you know and
not with everybody but there is a large
group of people that aren't as educated
and there was a guy when when Haiti when
people try and get out of Haiti to go to
the United States and the embassy there
there was a dude who would look at your
papers and stamp them yes or no well I
think I told you the story the guy had a
little [ __ ] r2d2 Star Wars thing here
so one guy was like well [ __ ] man he
likes r2d2 and he came back with another
Star Wars thing gave it to the guy the
guy for not for this reason but the guy
go thank you anything is okay your
papers are honored and he says dams yes
so word gets out that this dude worships
Star Wars and also it's good juju if you
know it got crazy because the guy at one
point had his holy thousand thousand
figurines like he's like guys you got to
stop doing this like now here's here you
go because it was all so superstitious
like maybe maybe the gods live excuse
yeah and so he freaks me out I watched
something from Hamilton Morris and
there's a dude like eating hot coals and
they were like sacrificing a goat and I
was like I couldn't even watch it so
that's cool shits do do [ __ ] that that's
tells like oh wow yeah parts how do you
eat hot coals I don't even thank you
but they were doing and they seemed fine
he was like eating it like how his teeth
I don't know I couldn't like I said I
was like I'm a lie yeah well I'm out of
this yeah boo do some weird [ __ ] still
goes on New Orleans so when you a lack
of education no matter where you are and
more yeah no matter where you are a lack
of education you know lack of schooling
is going to create various behaviors
hmm all due respect anybody from Haiti
yeah because they're listening yeah okay
so this 63 year old woman was just are
you okay
chin do me a favor that before she
giving this bring up the female gremlin
from gremlin to fry man hold on
I'm talking spot on female grim there's
hit it
tell me that doesn't look what's up bro
okay yes so much okay
there's a lipstick issues but other than
that comparison that weird and the nose
to it's impressive but you're so mean
their identity that's pretty obvious
that's impressive okay so this 63 year
old high school teacher was recently
arrested for having sex with a 17 year
old student she cried bud they don't
talk about whether it's a girl or a guy
they don't name the child or anything
but she is the newest sex scandal well
you just can't be here after dark
right yeah you can't feed after dark
definitely can't get water on her you're
17 you and your history teachers gave me
some business I feel you need an A I
felt bad for do you do you don't feel
bad for the kid
the 17 year old no really he's 17 he's a
he's a 17 year old boy yeah that's the
first you know yeah that's I think
that's legal in Vegas that's legal
that's legal in most countries and you
feel bad for her sweet old man is 15
she's a long a lady and she's not
married young man she provides no
intimacy in their life I feel bad I do I
do
oh well I haven't understand that double
standard if it's a dude I got a problem
I'm like I wouldn't be a good judge I'd
be like well she's a little more info
but she looks identical to that gremlin
let's do also the 17 year-old boy wasn't
he's like Keanu Reeves the owner the
problem any time is when
manipulate someone to do something they
don't want to do yeah right but we're
creating these rules about like when
that is when that happens and when that
happens when someone has the intellect
and the agency to make a correct choice
or when they're being manipulated by him
right that is if you don't it's I'm
giving you that sort of uh telling about
having a dick and putting it in somebody
that's different and being strong and
I'm an old lady a 63 year old lady isn't
that much of a threat is it she has that
the wisdom know she can talk to me into
it okay if you want this and harder in
class and he can't stand up she's
probably I don't think he does
when I was 17 I was all about you try to
hang you teach it off yeah well yeah I
mean yeah it looks like it carried away
I'm just saying but I think the reason
why it's why she got arrested a position
of power you are a teacher not have it
do when I was 17 and a teacher hit on
Mellie yeah I guess I have to come after
school and [ __ ] around with her we you
do have to arrest her I'm not taking on
a wrestler I did feel bad about the
situation I guess and a lot of times I
don't but with that I just I like your
ways my sense of double scary it's a hot
teacher I know I know
fantastic but you softer it's still not
a la hey if you're a teacher you can't
you can't
right no unless you're on it what if you
yeah if you're if you're a teacher of
anything you gotta like gotta lay off
you gotta lay off the kid like but what
about college professors were the kids
like 24 25 that's not illegal that's my
teacher get fired
it might just holla sometimes but but
that happens all the homeboy from
McDonald's gout he's [ __ ] 50 [ __ ]
27 right and he got fired because she
was a cashier at McDonough
but yes 70 mill he did well you gotta
pay up you gotta pay the man now I just
get let him go see you a McDonald's
cereza Magritte sometimes um sometimes
all that stuff is like that's not
illegal that's against policy she'll
lose your job yeah this is you this is
like the players can't sleep with the
cheerleaders yeah the cops are not gonna
arrest you you can lose weight
sleep with the cheerleaders absolutely
not why I'm found upon its round put its
frowned upon yes we announcement I know
yeah that's weird what happened I was
actually cash here
what then a McDonald's employee and he's
a CEO it's essential relationship why is
that bad why would you care yeah why is
that I guess it cuz you could give her
because he's the Big Dawg it's a lie son
she's getting promoted it's a liability
I guess it's a very interesting thing
because every situation we make laws
that are black and white and we make
rules and policies that are black and
white but really every situation is
unique is it was this a was this bad was
this abusive or was it not was even Z's
you can be in a whole other situation
and just be a [ __ ] Mentalist like
David Blaine somebody and completely
trick some girl into having sex with you
but you don't have any other relation
it's like oh I'm just being a pickup
artist yeah we're using like heavy
psychological influence technique well
Harvey Weinstein
right that's our different but all in
some case he's a racist so well no in
some case in the other case like if you
want to be in pretty woman - you're
gonna suck this dick and there are a lot
of girls who went alright that sounds
good to me
like that that's where so that's using
leverage that's our nitrogen power the
other one is just using is using like
influence and this kind of like but let
me ask you this black might ask you
something wrong sometimes guys are
attractive to women right and part of
what makes them attractive is the fact
that they are that they have a bed there
their seductive they're intelligent and
there are a lot of young women that are
into that no doubt deal so as power and
power is attractive to you so like all
of these my thing is though it works
somebody if you work with somebody you
know if you have a workplace because of
all of this stuff it would be it would
be always better to err on the side of
caution here's the thing most
relationships start that's right
environment that's right I don't think
it's gonna make people happier where you
gonna meet people I don't I get to know
people you in the same cute makes people
hey Mary how's it going you see her
every day and the authority position you
know I'm saying it's a guy and you are
gonna get surprised any problem with law
because really we should be judging
intention rather than actual like hangs
people
doing actually was I actually spent time
with like a super pastor this past
weekend and someone asked him about
about cuss words like saying [ __ ] or
something like that he's a cool guy
and he was like he's like you know what
it the word stone the words don't matter
it matters what the intent was if like
they were intending even if you say like
goddamn it he's like they were talking
even about saying that he's a pastor
right he's like that doesn't mean
anything if you didn't mean god damn it
like you weren't actually like damming
this or like actually like intending to
say something derogatory about the
divinity in general like you're just
saying a phrase it doesn't [ __ ] mean
anything you know what I mean so like
but people but religion has these
doctrines that say like don't say these
blasphemous words schools have these
things don't say these bad words she was
cool with it though yeah it was cool
with it cuz I was like I was like that's
awesome
I'd say [ __ ] yeah that's off exactly
[ __ ] yeah like that's the truth we see a
younger guy yeah for sure
and dress pretty cool yep yep yep yeah
and he was dope and it was like it was
like alright you get it it's not about
it's not about what you say it's about
what this is where they say McDonald's
CEO could fire for consensual and they
put that in quotes relationship with
wool you know if it was a relationship
did a lot of these relationships are
consensual it's just against their
policy though that's just one of the
rules down McDonald's has that policy
that makes sense and I understand it I
understand it's nobody sign up or then I
want to do with libel you know you sign
up for love that's true hey hey people
get lonely I don't give a [ __ ] how rich
you are what kind of CEO you're an older
guy you're a CEO you meet a girl you
connect there's something about her you
guys fall in love it just happens
[ __ ] maybe [ __ ] your job I don't know
maybe worth it we wanted that Rick
snitch Dunham catching the [ __ ] it was
like a lot of people my god Janine is
dating Gary I got a fire this I think
about that [ __ ] it's just we all love
to watch somebody die we love failure
but it makes people feel they just love
it makes us feel bunch of [ __ ] right
you keep on keepin on mr. chief officer
i Ken McDonald country and how hard
anymore
what else you got make matter food
they're doing their best makes it for
maybe better food to do it on us
okay so ate your best are they what are
they though all of us are on video all
the time you just can't do anything look
at this yeah we're on video all the time
what is this
so a couple days ago this video went
viral it's a mother coming up to a car
where a lyft driver and the passenger
are being yelled at because the lyft
driver almost accidentally hit her kid
she wasn't paying attention I guess they
were in like a section of this the road
and so they were in the way but he also
wasn't paying attention she was really
angry went to confront the lyft driver
and then she got mad at the passenger
for recording her and she's now being
called his book kids bop Karen also it's
a racist dish no it's not racist she's
just batshit crazy
this was the one who almost hit yeah
this is the mother and she thinks she
needs to take a video of it instead of
apologizing like a safe now being in the
middle of Rosa help you being a [ __ ] is
gonna help wait why she met at the
passenger she's filming oh this [ __ ]
you're clean
sorry but you're calling it [ __ ]
my kids gamer me calling you a [ __ ]
your windows open they can't hear me
because they're listening to kidsbox oh
she lays down a tough day she's also
lazy she was just angry about her just
crazy yeah just a little pray a little
okay you know crazy to be cooped up for
a couple days the kids should drive you
nuts man yeah yeah that's a bigger issue
than that yeah yeah that's a
an aggressive face that the tongue out
was and it was the interesting yeah this
was a good move it's very clear with her
words that it next one
sure so this interview came out earlier
today t I went on a radio interview
saying that he goes to the gynecologist
once a year with his 18 year old
daughter she just turned 18 and he says
that every single time they go to a
gynecologist he requires the doctor to
give him the results to make sure that
her hymen is intact
his daughter shed a lot of work done
that's Kylie's apparently she just
turned 18 the news about this came out
this morning how they saying worked on
she's just 18 so she's she's just young
that's how [ __ ] up we are in our
society we see an 18 year old her skin
would mean that tide yeah what she's 18
I believe this work you want to bet
Brian have you ever seen her before I've
seen before and afters her skin is tight
do you think that's what I'm referring
to
I'm a secret brother giant titties and
ways and this you old [ __ ] how things
coming up before and after chin what's
her name
they only had a show on vh1 for Dasia
okay I don't know I do I don't want you
might be thinking of his other daughter
the oldest daughter has a stepdaughter
nope
bring her up this one actors yeah died
one of them she's a diamond I mean she's
very cute but let's talk about the thing
man you can't [ __ ] do that to your
daughter like no no we're like weird
boys she's at the door door door she's
18 trouble sexes sex is like part of
life like like he's just gonna repress
it and she's gonna go [ __ ] wild
correct so I'm gonna work you know wild
out it's not gonna work man you know it
is in a way it's also him like doing a
client's a clumsy effort it's showing
his daughter he loves her it's a weird
kind of [ __ ] it's almost our thing I
think it's almost theatrical it's almost
like get her checked and I don't even I
don't even know if I believe it even
though he said it like sometimes it's
like yeah
you know I mean these things gonna be
just made a policy it was TMZ maybe may
not even be dr. with it people have that
mentality though and I think that
mentality is [ __ ] up where it's like
oh it's cool if my son has sex but if my
daughter has sex [ __ ] that like that's
not right he's always been that's always
that's a joke and yeah but like yeah it
could be joking anybody has a daughter
like I do know is that you have very
little control of their behavior at the
end of the day you're not doing these we
gotta raise them right yeah that's the
control person no matter what you know
and that's gonna actually cause them to
like not need love and validation
through other things and they have to
get some guy who's willing to give them
a little bit of love to put if they
didn't get at home yeah yeah they won't
they won't need that because they're
already like full of their own self love
and their own love from their family and
so that's the best [ __ ] thing you can
do yeah Donner let's figure it out I
want you to stay away there's a hero
here in Oakland you see this guy who
fell off the train the the edge of the
train area and just in the nick of time
actually pulled him up and you'll see
how close this was so he actually works
at the BART station there so this guy's
walking doesn't doesn't pay attention on
this phone falls down yep and they check
this out look I was like Batman
holy yeah yeah he's on his phone well I
probably shrinking because those Raiders
game oh [ __ ] oh my god that's close he
loses legs baby diapers and that's them
embracing the guy that works at the BART
station you own the guy that
[Applause]
which guy fell got the black shirt Wow
Wow that's [ __ ] amazing what a badass
people are crying and emotional of
course is that guy crying you know what
no there's a guy that got saved like a
like a disaster situation seen what
happened like what it like what your
reactions are slow down actually how
we're it's no well no it's weird cuz
like when something crazy happens a lot
of people freeze yes like well I was so
I was in Australia right and I'm I'm in
Australia and we're with a bunch of
people in my kitchen and there's a trick
where you can light regular bundaberg
rum off the spout and pour it in your
mouth and it'll go out by the time it
hits your mouth well this dude tried to
do it with over scenic you get what I'm
saying like you light the stream of
alcohol although fire goes and the fire
goes no but it goes out before it hits
your for it hits your mouth because it's
not just a strong aroma
all right we're party hard for heart
yeah anyways this dude tries it with
overproof rum so instead of it being
like 70 proof was 110 proof that's not
going right so he lights it it doesn't
[ __ ] go out hell yeah and then he
pours it so it's all over his face and
my kitchen and his face is on fire yeah
now his face is on fire like a [ __ ]
cartoon it was insane yeah and four
people are there with me frozen just
looking at him like I'm doing something
but I'm not doing the right thing there
was like towels I could have thrown over
his face I just went to the faucet and I
went I went to the faucet started
splashing water on his face yeah at
least I was in motion but I couldn't
think clearly enough lot of people feel
the right thing people have been in
high-pressure situations whatever it is
fighting whatever it's car accidents
beam every not what soldiers in real
high-pressure situations that's what
people that's where you herself yours
yours like crazy says live as you can
because they always say you sink to the
level of your training you don't rise to
the occasion so many bill and burning
buildings they would find them this
drives me nuts enemy they're pulling the
door as opposed to pushing the door come
on but they do but it's like ah [ __ ] I
know but they're they just they start
they're freaking out that bums me out
and you see that all the time well it's
also like when they've been now with the
FBI they don't allow you to pick your
shells up after you shoot so used to be
on the shooting range you shoot
Michels up because you get them out of
the way of the person who's there right
yeah don't do that anymore
why because they found FBI agents and
police officers dead because they
stopped to pick their [ __ ] shells up
because they in a high-pressure
situation Oh
go back to your training here's the
other thing though when you when you
take with the practice gun disarming a
gun you take it out of your partner's
hand then you give it a gun back to your
partner and he does it to you and you go
back and forth and they would give the
gun problem is there was a guy who was
with his partner and he goes he took the
gun exactly took the gun away and gave
it back to the his partner how to shoot
him because because he had been
practicing that so in anything you do
you have to practice for the real thing
or you will revert back to those those
when you practice something practice the
wrong thing you're gonna good at the
wrong thing and then those certain
people it just depends - like if you've
been in high-pressure situations
whatever it is in a different field and
you put in that same high pressure
situation you're gonna react different
than everybody else you're gonna [ __ ]
out things army a little slower for you
right my friend Roger Huerta was one of
those people who would do the right
thing in those situation a couple things
were like one like a ladder was falling
over right and all of us someone's on
the ladder everybody's like oh like just
looking just like runs underneath and
just holds it well Roger work does Roger
work does given some intense situations
what he's at the think there's a fire
right yeah yeah top top fighter so like
there's some people who can university
apply because you never practice for
your friends face catching fire like you
would never really mentally rehearse
that I know right I like that your
friends face what happen if he was fine
all right all this all his hair got
burned off his eyelashes his eyebrows he
had some burning away works could have
been way worse way worse yeah that's
that's past but this guy I mean that the
impressive thing is like he didn't
freeze and he did the right thing and he
acted immediately yeah and that's a rare
human it's a special human yeah no
hesitation
yeah same goddamn life oh my god this
one did you know that Kelly Clarkson and
John Legend are redoing a song baby it's
cold outside
right so a good thing to remake maybe
you know either yeah you know the
remaking it because of the rape unit
so they're changing the lyrics and the
lyrics are really really bad what my
[ __ ] with it but it's all rapey is it it
is but it's also just a Christmas what's
the new what's the old lyrics well look
at the new one first what my friends
think what were my things
I think they should rejoice about I have
one more drink it's your body your
choice
and I really can't stay I've got to go
away I can call you I can call you a
ride politically correct culture let me
see what hold where's the original [ __ ]
use original damn you're creepy I think
it's I think it's like a great song no
no I don't you don't think he needs no
it doesn't stop rape it doesn't make is
thank you [ __ ] off no rapist like ah
yeah I really can't stay by because I've
got to go away but maybe it's cold this
evening I've been hoping that you drop
in so very nice I'll hold your hand
they're like ice my my mom will start to
worry well he says what's your hurry my
father will be pacing
he says girl check out the fire so
really I better scary come on don't go
but maybe just half a drink more
put some records on while I pour the
neighbors might think baby it's bad out
there this is the one say what's in the
drink
no cash we had [ __ ] you can't go
anywhere right the you rises drink in
your eyes
I wish I knew how your eyes are like
starlight to break this spell I'll take
your hat you're here like swell so
babies just saw you say no no no sir
mind if I move in closer my sister will
be suspicious he goes gosh your lips
look delicious robbery classic song it
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't create
rape culture it doesn't make people more
real it's it's a creepy song ending how
you look at it other way I never thought
I've heard this song a thousand times I
never once thought of it that way I
thought of it it was it was just a good
tune and I thought of as the guy in love
with her she likes him too but she wants
to wait a little longer and they're
trying to like Athena go that's a lovely
story Brian actually it seems like she's
dying out there and he's not half of it
exactly there's no cabs to be had this
was like not really want to get going I
really don't want another drink let's do
one more yeah whoo Bert there's no beru
burrs who was down no every guys just
hang out whatever we're just hanging out
have another have another drink every
guys done that
doesn't mean you're a rapist to try to
keep them there because you'll like them
the Fox tribe you keep the ball with
every [ __ ] angusamy correct Portia is
so bad and so full of [ __ ] the other
lurches know their lyrics are horrible
I'll get you I'll call just let's just
leave this song alone just let it just
let it fade off yeah or whatever or sing
it and teach your body it's your choice
god I think you just picture John Legend
gun it's your body it's your choice [ __ ]
you Oh God [ __ ] boring people [ __ ]
[ __ ] boar's and you unfunny what will
my friends neighbours he goes tell these
[ __ ] brought it I'll have one
more drink at your body to your choice
[ __ ] we can't stay Irena we got to go
away I can
all you a ride this guy sounds like a
quitters really sounds like a great man
you gotta forget kind of a voice on you
man you could do some do some things no
thanks yeah man go bet
I'm impressed thanks dude baritones you
know to warm my you could do your own
Christmas you could do a Christmas album
I'm gonna got that up it might me and
Michael Buble are gonna do big Brown's
Christmas yeah big Brown's Christmas
could be a platinum record all Energy's
la friends yeah that has left Brian's
body no I'm on your phone that's not you
know he's got this I can always tell
there it is let's do it on an app what's
your favorite on the product that you
use most often no terrible app you check
this out on it has their new coffee
what is it kick out a copy dude black
rifle best coffee on planet earth and on
it combined
it's called kick ass coffee coffee it's
[ __ ] yeah coffee [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
coffee doesn't work I posts on my story
this morning you know I take so much
[ __ ] as far as you know uppers and
caffeine it takes a lot to get me going
I drink probably eight cups coffee in
the morning i text you this morning un
man on the group [ __ ] text i had one
cup of that I was a [ __ ] bone man
really I was on that pill it's got extra
Cassidy yes crystals so they meth
yeah they roasted beef they roast the
beans so it's like it's black rifle [ __ ]
they do a great job roasting the beans
but then they add caffeine crystals into
the beans you see yourselves so it's
like you know like when you get that
nice nugget of well but you now
everybody gets like pre-rolled joints
but used to get that nice nugget of weed
and all the crystals on it and it's like
wow this is some cush
yeah you know these are like cush beans
yes I got that extra caffeine crystal
own genes this is so my let's say if I
go to drink black right well but if I
don't and I'm at Starbucks if I'm at
Starbucks on you like Amir Khan oh I get
so they put whatever three shots in it
as you do four to five that's and that
doesn't nothing to your boy yeah that
does
knocking drink then go to sleep I took
one cup of this and I'm telling you dude
mmm you were shaking nope nope just good
don't get Chris on fire it's not just
not fading I know
you should have had some I'm all about
it all energy left your Baba can't
coffee from on it
Hottentot complex fighter 10% off put
some [ __ ] almond milk latte
MCT oil on that [ __ ] - why not why not
got your [ __ ] guns my face on there
and a teddy bear on my face on there
yeah yeah yeah Quito is [ __ ] well you
know I left a bag who designed the bag
on it yeah
yes dope nineties rad dude I can't wait
for come kung fu commercially come out
let's go it's brown scornful yes
your your plantar fasciitis hey I want
to tell you guys I want to tell you guys
look I know a lot of people who do stuff
like this and I have a lot of like
business related people but you guys are
really good friends like you guys are
really really three of us yeah you guys
are good friends to each other to me
like oh yeah I just want everybody to
know like you guys are really good like
a really good friend oh yeah we love you
man yeah I love you guys yeah we
appreciate that man yeah yeah that's
we've always felt that way though the
one thing I remember about you is when
we said what do you want to say about on
it when we first became another problem
you go like this you go no you go just
be honest and I was like this
[ __ ] did that honest I just
always loved that about you you've
always tackled whatever challenges you
have and you trying to do it with you do
it the best you can with this whole
situation with this celibacy thing
mm-hmm
and I'll let you know when if someone
sits on my face Hey so it's it's
cheating on my face yeah I'll tell you
I'll let you know yeah I'll keep you
posted
yeah and I'll and also like just you
know little I'll funnel people your way
use my face you know you use your face
as a surrogate I'm just gonna say
they're just gonna laugh laugh laugh
until they come the calm there's nothing
wrong laughing incoming if you don't
like laughing and coming then was way
wrong with you when I permit I'll we had
a plan alright maybe don't put on me
Jack in the cord yeah a [ __ ] mask
well thanks coming on dude Bobbie Marcus
I love you love you man thanks pal have
you guys see this the [ __ ] kid we're
out